welcome back there's now an arrest
warrant for an unnamed suspect accused
of killing an American woman vacationing
in Mexico shankwella Robinson lived in
Charlotte North Carolina and was on a
trip with friends in Cabo the local
prosecutor in Mexico says one of the
friends one says quote friends traveling
with Robinson was her killer he's now
working with American authorities to
have that woman x-rated back to Mexico
to face charges when medical
professionals first examine Robinson at
her Villa they say she was alive but
drunk and dehydrated they suggested
Robinson's friends take her to a
hospital but they declined later First
Responders returned after Robinson had a
seizure they reportedly tried CPR
multiple times but could not resuscitate
in an autopsy report officials say
Robinson had a severe spinal cord injury
and dislocated neck we asked forensic
death investigator Joseph Scott Morgan
what investigators need to be on lookout
for
it would take you know probably repeated
blows uh twisting those sorts of things
in this area quite a bit of trauma so
one of the things you're going to be
looking for in a postmortem exam is to
look for any kind of other Associated
areas of hemorrhage that are surrounding
you know the muscular tissues and those
sorts of things and any evidence of of
fracturing of anything in there it
fractions you can actually compromise
this area without what would be
considered to be a fracture you know we
see these things that are put forth in
entertainment where people's necks are
snapped and all that sort of thing that
you don't have to go to that link to you
know to fracture a bone in order to
compromise the structural Integrity of
that area
Terry do you think this person will be
x-rayed to Mexico immediately or will
the FBI step in to prosecute first well
well I do think because there is an
extradition agreement between Mexico and
the United States I do think that they
will cooperate and have a timing
agreement for this and that agreement
has been in place since 1978 so I think
they've done this before and frankly I
think to go back to Mexico where it
actually happened that's where all of
the evidence is let that proceed first
in my opinion because it will get cold
eventually if you don't go after it and
then after that case is resolved bring
her back here and prosecute her under
the United States law so I think we'll
be able to do both and frankly I think
they should do Mexico first and then
come back here yeah I don't think that's
Double Jeopardy because it's two
different countries but I got to double
check that one that's outside of my
jurisdiction Bernardo you've been
following the case closely does Joseph
Scott Morgan's Insight give new light to
where this case may go
well the insight there Joseph Scott
Morgan who is a pro gives us is
definitely what we knew which it wasn't
an accidental it wasn't something that
was self-inflicted so it gives you the
cause of death because for any homicide
prosecution you have to link and make
sure that the cause of death and the
manner of death is a homicide but in
Mexico they're charging it at the
defendant side because Sean Paulo
Robinson was a female who was attacked
in a violent matter but we're hoping to
hear something soon because we haven't
really gotten substantiated information
from the news or from Mexico so
hopefully we'll hear something soon
about what's really going on and what
happened on that fatal day especially
with this extradition that Terry talked
about the quicker that person gets sent
back to Mexico the quicker they get
question the quicker hopefully the
family and we get some answers now to
Buffalo New York where a white gunman
pled guilty Monday to killing 10 black
people in a supermarket the 19 year old
shooter entered the plea to murder and
hate motivated terrorism charges in May
the shooter armed with a modified
semi-automatic rifle people killed three
people in a parking lot before entering
Tops Friendly Market once inside the
store he shot and killed seven others
the entire thing was live streamed on
Twitch through a camera on the gunman's
helmet
the shooter isn't as an admitted white
supremacist during Monday's plea hearing
he confirmed to the judge that he killed
each person because of their race the
highest punishment imposed comes from
the charge of hate motivated domestic
terrorism carrying an automatic sentence
of life in prison without parole but he
could face the death penalty if
convicted on federal hate crime charges
the U.S justice department has not said
yet if they will seek capital punishment
involving another Supermarket shooting
we have updates for you in the Walmart
Massacre out of Chesapeake Virginia
authorities have released a Death Note
from the Walmart supervisor accused of
carrying out last week's attack the 31
year old shot six of his employees
inside the store before turning his
legally purchased nine millimeter
handgun on himself the shooter along
with two others were found dead on
arrival before other victims died from
their injuries in the note found on the
shooter's phone he accused his
colleagues of giving him quote Twisted
grins the shooter also accused them of
celebrating his downfall on his last day
of work saying quote that's why they
suffer the same fate as me the note
ended with a shooter writing quote my
God forgive me for what I'm going to do
the gunman had no criminal history and
had to work for a Walmart for more than
a decade